j'ai vu justin bieber hier tout le monde
voulait voir tout le monde voulait voir
et je suis allé voir il partait parce
qu'il enregistrait le grand journal hier
qui passera demain d'ailleurs un sur
canal+ pourrait voir justin bieber
demain mais là j'ai attrapé et je vais
vous dire il s'est passé quelque chose
je crois on s'était fait regarder la
musique ilike et lala lala lala lala
notre meilleur ennemi pantalon je suis
le nouveau texte
on s'ouvre allez salut salut frérot
comme en salle qui fait justin salut
frérot stocky tu pars avec tous féraud
et attend il ya pas ma carte bleue dans
l'est je sais je crois que ma carte
plein dans les restes mortels
ma pitcher ma carte bleue
mais découle j'aime beaucoup ce garçon
j'aime beaucoup parce qu il devait
partir en fait de style bieber est là
bas un avion dix minutes après ils
m'attendaient le pauvre dans le hall
c'est un amour en vraiment parce qu'on
est en train de mal mais il a voulu me
foute a pas il est vrai je vous le jure
il est vraiment parti avec ma veste bien
les partis n'ont heureusement il ya en
fait j'ai laissé ma carte mais c'est ma
carte jean il pourra rien retirer vous
dire non mais vraiment super sympa le
gars qu'on a parlé un petit peu avant
mais comme le cadreur était en train de
prendre un café on n'a pas pu filmer
donc mais sans rigoler cadreur je sais
pas où ils étaient en fait il est en
train de se servir du papy brossard au
sénat prévoit là et après donc il est
arrivé donc on est en train de discuter
tranquillement
[Musique]
ans
jacques hopin ya une meuf à lui renvoyer
ces paroles genre boîte de you mean qui
parlait pas anglais l'a fait google
translate pendant toute la nuit
c'est le seul pour qui ce qui est très
bas bartois passer une journée avec
justin bieber puisque c'était la
question oui il a tout pour lui chante
bien il danse bien il est beau il
organise des poudres on se marre bien
non mais je dis on va être honnête il
sait se marrer il sait ce mari et
manager à l'hôtel il fait venir plein de
vie plein match il est drôle mais je
pense quand je rigolerai bien une
journée avec banjo steam bieber on va
voir c'est que les rencontres et je sais
vous allez me donner votre chemise
il est normal reste arrive est sans
faille de dans exactement il était hyper
sympa tu estimes bieber vraiment a prévu
un super ça vaut aussi des terrains
bieber j'aime bien justin bieber c'est
vrai que j'ai rien j'aime bien fiable à
justin bieber et j'aime bien mylène
farmer mais c'est pas pour ça que je
vais franchir
il a mis sa carrière entre parenthèses
de ses malheurs aux ordres
il a aussi ses soucis psychologiques qui
refait surface
donc là on a appris le souci écologique
je peux vous poser une question what do
you mean
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on cherche à s'amuser